[Music]
i feel like i'm a cash cow you're her
husband man i don't think she's ever uh
she's always had a safety net i don't
think she's ever been desperate
like i have she's your wife
what's the matter with you dude what do
you mean she's my wife what does that
have to do with it i am my wife's safety
net
all right
what's up this is john with the dr john
dolone's show
so glad that you're with us
talking about marriage and parenting and
mental health and whatever's else is
going on in your life on the greatest
marriage and parenting and mental health
podcast in the history of the planet
um
and since podcasts have been around for
like 10 years
it's a bold statement bold statement you
want to be on the show give me a buzz
1-844-693-3291 that's eight four four
six nine three three two nine one um or
you can go to johndaloni.com
ask and fill out the four markets don't
you nudity too
and then uh jenna will give you a buzz
not a
what are the drinks called white claw
yes those like hard seltzers i think so
yeah like it's like alcohol for kids for
children it's like what we used to drink
in high school like bartles and james
exactly but skittles an inch okay
that's not the kind of buzz jenna will
give you is what i'm trying to say
um she will not
she will she
while intoxicating i'm just just turning
this into an hr mess she is intoxicating
she's not going to give you a buzz
um she's going to call you i'm on all
right let's go to brian in evanston this
thing's just going to get off the rails
before we get going what's up brian
hey how's it going what's up you money
good dude you
good it's uh good to talk to you again
you too man again have we talked before
yeah yeah
you actually named uh the episode after
my thing
oh so quick insider baseball i don't
ever name any of the episodes that's
pretty cool that's kelly's job
very cool somebody did yeah there you go
hey so what's up man
hey hold on what did we talk about last
time
uh my about my ex-wife and how she's an
emotional terrorist
and uh it was i think it was back in
april so it was quite a while ago
every i don't quite remember it but
everyone in the booth was like oh yeah
we remember brian all right
so welcome back brian it's good to see
you again
yeah uh thanks for having me um
yeah so my question was like i'm kind of
frustrated with my wife and
and i'm trying to keep it from turning
into resentment from her okay this is
your current wife
yeah yeah my current wife okay and uh
you know she's she's been going to
school to get her bachelor's degree
and uh you know it's taken her 10 years
and you know she started with an
associates okay and uh you know she's
racked up a bunch of student loan debt
and uh you know now she's she's at the
end here and you know she keeps failing
this test she has to take
and every time it's like 150 bucks
and i mean uh i mean i don't think she's
stupid for sure like she's smart
i just don't understand why she keeps
failing it
and uh
you know i i'm almost starting to resent
her for it because i mean it's like i'm
financing her dreams while i have to
work a job that i really don't like
just so we can pay the bills you know
uh
i'm trying to think of where to start
so right out of the gate you already
resent her dude you don't like her
you're annoyed by her and she pisses you
off let's just cut to it like yeah let's
be honest she does
um
that's a tough place to be
um what is she going to school for
what's taken 10 years to get 60 credit
hours
early childhood development
um and uh
you know
but there's no exit test for
for so it's
for her certification it's called the
praxis test okay
yeah what does she want to do
she wants to you know uh she wants to
work with special ed kids
but you know with that degree with her
degree she could go you know work up to
like uh teach up to like third grade i
think so sh let me just be real clear
she has no interest in doing this
she hasn't for a decade i would hope she
does she this is like her dream
it's absolutely not 100 it's not
i guarantee you it's not
here's how i know here's how you know
um and dude you're gonna have to chill
out and i know you're pissed off but you
have to chill out
um
yeah
if this was her dream
she would have done 60 hours in 18
months
there would there's a
year around if when you're around people
who are obsessive
about a dream the thing that they really
want to do
they make it happen
they don't take a decade to get 60 hours
and you're talking to a guy they got two
phds and had kids and i was working a
full-time job and i was married i was
obsessed
right yeah we got we got four kids she
works at the school right now as a para
educator or whatever and
i know dude can you just hear your voice
you don't like her
i don't like what she's doing no no you
don't like her
why
why i like to think that i like her at
least
i would too she she's the mother of your
kids four years on this
is it something yeah
i feel like i'm a cash cow
you're her husband i feel like
yeah but i feel like i'm just her cash
cow because i mean you know she's
she's going through all the schooling
costing a bunch of money and like she
like she didn't work all summer
and you know we've been doing the dave
ramsey thing trying to pay off debt she
she didn't want to get a job this whole
summer
and she doesn't make any money while
she's while she's off
and you know so i've been i've been
supporting the family for three months
now and and you know
it's just it's frustrating me
pretty bad and and i can't even tell her
about it because then she'll start
crying and and uh you know it because uh
she'll shut down much like she'll just
climb right up
i dude i'm claiming right up now talking
to you
why
because man you're coming at me like i
did something like your whole your whole
ain't you you are so full of anger
i can hear it in you man
and the way you just come
you're not interested in a discussion or
hey what's next
it'd say i've got to get this out and
let me be honest it's okay to do that
it's super okay right i'm not gonna hurt
my feelings um
but i absolutely can see you being a lot
my question for you is this this is not
the ultimate issue
there's something beneath this or
beneath that and here's let me throw a
couple of ideas out there number one
you got how old your your oldest kid
15 15 and what's your youngest
uh should be five next month okay
so
you've got four kids things are chaotic
bills are very very tight
you found yourself in a mess
you're um with a 15 year old all the way
down to a five-year-old i'm just
guessing here this is most couples this
doesn't have to be you your sex life's
screwed up your time alone with your
wife is screwed up your friends are
screwed up like it's just you're just
running and running and running
and whenever we're running running
running we start looking for who's not
doing their right and so it becomes this
woe is me woe is me kind of thing
um that could be one of them
it could be that you don't like who
you've become
and i'm gonna go right i don't know what
the deal is but there's something
beneath the thing what is the thing
beneath the thing
i'm not attracted to my wife anymore i
think she's lazy i don't like her
character like what is the thing beneath
the thing
because this is
it's been going on for 10 years brother
and so
it would have boiled up before now is
what i'm saying
i guess maybe maybe i don't like her
character i don't like her i don't
really like her work ethic
she you know she almost seems like she
just doesn't care about uh anything who
takes care of these four kids
well uh we we you know she's at home
with them right now just because she's
uh
uh you know it's summer vacation and uh
but they'll be in school
you know i mean i'm home every night uh
you know even though i'm a truck driver
but
you know i'm there with her
but like you know she's just sitting
around all day
watching reality tv and crap
and uh you know
have you ever stayed at home with four
kids
yeah
yeah i've done that and there's just
nothing going on
she just sitting around well
well yeah i mean she's you know she's
just sitting around uh you know the kids
are tearing the house apart and
you know it's not necessarily that i
need her to i want her to clean up you
know like the house has to be immaculate
and dinner has to be on the table when i
get home but
you know i mean like uh she's you know
it just doesn't seem like she's putting
forth any effort
uh like it's almost like she just
doesn't care i mean like
we don't even think the same about money
we you know she she sees
like 500 bucks in our account and and i
see no money
and you know and we can't even get we
can't even be on the same page about
that
why you know it's like we're living two
separate lives that's that's it right
there
that's it right there what
i mean i don't know how i'm gonna i
don't know how i can because if i if i
try to
give her
maybe some advice i i probably do come
off as overbearing and arrogant 100
and
yeah and and you know but like she said
she's telling me well why is your way
the right way
that's a very fair question
it's a fair question that's a fair
question but i i don't think she's ever
uh she's always had a safety net i don't
think she's ever been desperate
like i have she's your wife what's the
matter with you
dude what do you mean she's my wife what
does that have to do with it
i don't ever
ever i am my wife's safety net
well i and she's mine
i don't ever want my wife to have to
feel desperate what are you talking
about
i'm just saying in her younger years
she's never had to feel
desperate like with money you know
i i i'm her safety net i where i go out
work 70 hours a week and
you know i mean i i take care of them
i don't want her to feel desperate now
but i'm just saying she never did and
that's why i think that's why she feels
that like money is not important or
something
you know
i don't know i am arrogant and i have a
big ego i can admit that so uh
here's what it sounds like dude can i be
honest with you
it sounds like you are real real
freaking lonely
sounds like you are
real lonely
and i'm surrounded by people that's
exactly right
and you're drowning yes right on a boat
full of people
and
it was a revelation to me
when i learned
that
male depression often male loneliness
male depression often
comes out
with volume with anger with you need to
fix fill in the blank
and anytime i'm sitting with somebody
like i am with you right now
who is who is this much disdain for his
wife
and yes you could say i love her if
somebody tried to come into the house
i'd fight them all yes you could do the
willam william wallace stuff but you
don't like her you have disdain for her
and that's not like just my wife but
like
you wouldn't marry this person again
if you knew them
and
that circles back in this world to you
and quite unfortunately she's on the
phone so you never call me one day and i
talk to her about all of her soap opera
watching and her bon bon eating which i
i take issue with that's a whole other
call
what do you need man
i don't know what do you need you do you
do man what do you need
what's scaring you i i feel like i feel
like she doesn't no no quit talking
about her
what scares you okay
uh
i i guess being completely alone with no
people around me or something
uh
that that that scares me being divorced
again and
hey you you are real real close to that
and you know that
yeah have you started talking to
somebody else
about divorce no i don't like i don't
have no no no no not about divorce
is that
are you talking to somebody else are you
seeing somebody else are you texting
somebody else oh no no no no okay no i'm
no cheater okay
um yeah this thing's dangerous to
dangerously close to getting off the
rails
but again you've been down this road you
know that
what scares you
are you scared about money man are you
scared about not having enough are you
scared about your kids
are you scared about the world what are
you scared about
i'm scared about never ever making
enough money
and she and you know
stop stop right there what can you do
about that
i don't know
make more money i suppose
have you i i don't know
have you ever sat down with your wife
and said i'm scared
yeah
and she just said i don't care and then
move over uh
real housewives of atlanta is coming on
yeah she says we're fine
like why are you scared we're fine
is she right you know
not well i mean maybe it to a point
but you know like i i don't feel like
we're fine and i feel like once you get
to the point where you're fine and you
don't have this anxiety
then
you're going to end up like you know
uh losing losing everything in the end
why why do you think that man
i don't know maybe i know i'm i'm pretty
pessimistic i like to think of myself as
a realist but
um you know i i just i just feel like if
i'm not
anxious about you know getting the
mortgage paid then the mortgage won't
get paid
have you ever missed a payment you know
no okay so the data tells me you're a
guy that pays his bills
yeah
and
you're also telling me you're a guy
who's on a plan to get out of debt
you are
yeah but i'll tell you as a guy that
nearly burned my wife to the ground
with my anxiety
and my oh yeah but this could happen and
what about this what about this and what
about this
and i had an emergency fund for our
emergency fund
and
we i wouldn't take vacations for a
decade so that i could pay this off so i
could pay that off
and eventually my wife said i don't want
this life
yes we may hear here ultimately brother
here was the line that that was the
bellwether line for me and it wasn't
from my wife it was from my buddy and i
came to find out that she had talked to
him and said i'm worried about john
and the line he gave me because we were
talking about money he's a banker he's a
savant
and we were talking about this and what
about the dollar and then what happens
here and how much do i need saved and
then what about the investment here and
i'm gonna put this in
and finally he said dude i don't have a
meteorite plan
i said what does that mean
and he said i got
like i'm saving money i'm trying to pay
off my debts and all that but
dude if the dollar implodes and we're
trading gold and coffee i'll deal with
that when we get there because i'm gonna
have to shoot my neighbor's dog for food
and what i would tell you is you have a
plan
what you don't have
is the skill set to be an engaged father
you do not have the skill set to be an
engaged loving present husband those are
tools and skills you don't have
and until you decide i want to get those
your body feels like it's on fire every
time you're around them and it gets
pushed off into proxy things like money
and if you guys got a million dollars
today within a month it would be about
something else how clean the house is
and then you hire a maid and then within
a month it would be about something else
your body's gonna continue to
find something to blame to heal the
internal to put a band-aid over that
internal chaos which is relationship
and until you are enough of a brave
courageous man which i'm hoping this
phone call is that
to say
i am scared of being alone
i'm scared of my 15 year old son or
daughter looking at me and saying i
don't like being around that guy
or a five-year-old that would rather
play a video game than be engaged with
his old man
then you say i don't have enough i don't
have the skills the tools i don't know
how to do this and i'm gonna go learn
those skills and tools and i'll tell you
right now you can turn all that around
that's that's where we are
along the way
you will have to address your
conversation with your wife but that's
not where you start brother you start in
the mirror
and you work too hard and you love too
deeply to feel this alone
is that fair
yeah yeah
i just don't know where to start i don't
know how to do that
i feel like i'm lying to myself you know
you are
you are
you are and here's the other thing this
is it's as common thing with men myself
included here right
is
i'm not i i don't know how to i don't
know how to
do dad i'm not good at it
and when i tried early on my wife was
like what are you doing that's how you
do a diaper that no you got to warm the
bottle up to this not to that you can't
put that in the microwave what do you
and i found myself early on i was better
at work than i was at home so i just
started spending time there because
that's where i was good at what i did
and i felt like i could help there
and you probably heard me talk about the
show it was just this this year that my
wife looked at me with her hands on my
face and said john we have enough
we need you
and then i thought oh crap i don't know
how to do that
yeah see what i'm saying
yeah
so it sounds like your wife has not
checked out of
uh it's not lazy it sounds like she's
she's
she quit
because you're probably a lot
i have a loss i'll give you that and my
guess is she doesn't have a path to
victory with you
is that tell me i'm wrong you can say
dolan you're full crap you're wrong
no i think you're i think you're right
but if she got her degree right now and
she went and got a job
she may have awareness that there's you
may not think i'm doing anything but
somebody the laundry of four kids plus a
a driver has to get done
and this has to get done and that has to
get done all these things have to get
done the live house will still move on
and
i'm gonna go make 40 000 and within a
few months my husband brian's gonna ask
me why aren't you making 50. and why
aren't you making 60. all right like i'm
just gonna sit here i'm out
and again i may be way out to lunch on
that dude
i would like to think that that you know
her making 40 grand would be a big help
uh
would it i i don't know i it seems like
well yeah i mean i like i'm almost
obsessed with paying off debt
and it's like she doesn't care i feel
like i'm dragging her to get to you know
to pay off debt
yeah and i
maybe i'm not i
you might you might actually be but what
i'm gonna tell you is you're you're
gonna not only not pay off your debt by
doing that you're gonna lose your
marriage too
yeah and at some point you'll have to
come together because the whole point of
doing something together like this
the reason that you pay off debt with
somebody else is because it forces you
to the table to say who do we want to
become who do we want to be where we
want to go
and let's do the things that we need to
do to get there
and that often not always not honestly
even often
sometimes it results in people need to
go get counseling because i know i want
to lose 100 pounds and i know that it's
diet and exercise for some reason i
can't stop and i need to go get some
help i need to talk to somebody i need
to do this i need that i'm i'm the exact
same way i gotta i have a coach right
now i got a counselor right i got people
that help me do my stuff and i do this
for a living i know the answers but i
gotta i gotta have some more tools right
um
is your 15 year old a boy girl
she's a girl
tell me about your relationship with her
well she i i'm not 100 sure she likes me
um hold on say that in a more honest way
i think she hates me
i think her mother turned turned her
against me okay she tried to commit
suicide twice in my house okay i
admitted her twice to a uh
mental institution uh to get treatment
and uh you know she actually wrote a
letter to me
attacking me
and uh you know blaming me for all of
her problems and the therapist that she
was seeing actually said that she
attacked me because she felt safe with
me
or some crap like that
i didn't believe her the therapist uh
and
she actually had a one-on-one session
with me because apparently i was really
agitated
but uh brian
she's put she's been through a lot way
more than what any kid should be
you know who else has been through a lot
you
who
oh
yeah brian your daughter tried to die
twice
and she blamed you for it
and by the way your therapist was
probably right
how old was she
oh she was uh 12. and she tried it twice
within six months
you know what we don't let 12 year olds
do we don't let them drive
we don't let them buy guns or beer
because they're kids
you know and as much as what she said
hurt you deeply you did not fail that 12
year old girl in fact you're her
lifeline
and 12 year olds say crazy things i have
a 12 year old now
and they do crazy things because they're
12.
but you're not a crappy dad
you didn't fail your kid you didn't
break your kid
well
i mean i i failed her when she was six
really
you know her one of her mom's boyfriends
assaulted her for two years under her
nose and
that was pretty bad did you know that
i didn't find out until my ex-wife
called me and said we're heading over to
the hospital because we got to do a rape
kit on kylie and i'm like then you
didn't fail your daughter did you show
up
i was there yeah
then you were there with her in the fire
my brother
listen
until you let brian off the hook
everything's going to feel like it's on
fire
yeah
i thought i thought against call you
don't like uh your wife and that may be
true um
you don't like brian i think i don't i
think i hate myself i don't think so i
know so
yeah
and that's got to stop because you're a
good dad
you're dead filled with rage and if my
little i have a six-year-old little girl
and if i found out she'd been sexually
assaulted
i would be filled with rage too to the
point that i couldn't breathe and i
couldn't see
okay and if one of my if my 12 year old
tried to hurt himself and blame me for
it i would be sick and disgusted and i
could call myself a failure your
responses have been right but that
doesn't mean they're true
yeah
yeah i guess
no i don't guess i don't guess
i'm telling you have i ever lied to you
yet
no no
no i mean i just i feel like a pretty
bad dad exactly
and the way most men deal with i feel
pretty bad is i got to blame somebody
else because i don't have the tools to
look in the mirror and say whoa what
happened
so you think i'm throwing all that crap
on my wife i'm almost guaranteeing you
are or you're creating a home that makes
it hard to win in
i don't know your knee i don't know how
i can meet your needs to a way where you
will be at peace because you have no
peace you have no capacity for peace and
so when i try to meet your needs
then it comes out somewhere else and
somewhere else and somewhere else and at
some point i'm out
i'm out because i can't i can't i can't
it's like playing a baseball game in the
and there's no strike zone they just
keep calling strikes and you don't know
where the like i'm not gonna i'm just
quit batting i don't know what we're
doing here
now if your wife was on the phone with
me
i would
be having a hard conversation with her
but she's not and ultimately at the end
of the day
you cannot control her behavior
you can't control what she does what she
doesn't do the fact that she's failing
exams she's feeling a test that she's
taken 10 years to do something that was
really
uh one to two years at most of a project
right
you can't
you can't fix any of that stuff
and yelling and screaming and being
pissed off i just sends people into
fight or flight and there's not a lot of
accomplishment that comes on the back
end of that
what you need to do yelling scream at
her
i know dude but you're like i don't want
to stress her out even more for the next
test you know i know i know but dude you
know what makes it even
me and you are more similar than than
you think
and you know what my superpower was i
never ever ever yell when i'm pissed
never
but dude i can be really violent with my
silence
my silence can fill up a room
it's a nuclear reactor energy and my
kids know to back out my wife knows to
not engage and then i can be righteous
and have all the indignation the world
be like
i didn't say anything what oh oh
everybody hates dad because i'm so tired
because i've been working my butt off
right
no i knew exactly what i was doing
in fact if i yell people can point at me
and go that guy's crazy but if i'm a
nuclear reactor you know what they do
they go in the mirror and think they're
crazy
yeah
so i like manipulation almost kind of so
here's the here's your path forward my
brother okay
path number one is
you're gonna have to write brian
the brian that nine years ago
found out that somebody sexually
assaulted his daughter
you're gonna have to write that brian a
thank you letter and say thank you for
showing up and doing the best you could
in the single most nightmarish situation
i can imagine
it's pretty bad it is
and you're gonna have to write the brian
of three years ago four years ago
another letter
that says you are such a good father
that you're the only one that i spun out
terrified terrified little 12 year old
child
could throw a dart at
because even she was wise enough to know
that mom's
too reactive i can't i can't mom's not
safe
and you need to write that guy note that
says thank you for loving your daughter
even though that hurt
yes and then you're gonna have to go sit
down with your wife and say i'm sorry
i've been scared for 10 years
i haven't liked myself for 10 years i've
been walking around with stories in my
head for 10 years
i'm anxious
i'm alone
and i need you to hear me say here's a
couple things i'm really scared about
i'm scared about
ending up completely alone i'm scared
about not having enough money for these
kids
i'm scared that another one of my kids
is gonna hate me and try to hurt
themselves again i need to put those
things on the table the word that nobody
likes to say especially tough guys
is vulnerable you have to say
you can hurt me with what i'm about to
tell you and i'm asking you not to
and what i'll tell you is this brian
you're gonna feel comfortable
if you did all those three things
even you're gonna take one one step
further if you read those two letters
that you wrote to nine year nine years
ago brian and
uh three or four years ago brian you
read those to your wife
and then you sat down with her and had
this conversation
after all this then you can sit down and
you get to the point and say i don't
know what to do about your school
i'm harboring a lot of frustration and
and anger
because i feel like you don't want to be
finished
and i feel like i've created a world
where you can't win
right
take ownership uh do you you know jocko
is like
my buddy giaco he like yes like take
ownership just take it even if it's not
all your blame take i'm gonna take
ownership of this
i'm gonna need to do some healing to
learn some new skills and
i'm gonna need us to dream together
and all of this is a completely
uncharted water for you this is you
walking out into the woods with a
machete saying i got a cart i got to cut
my own path here gun what i'm doing
but i will tell you this
being raged up and pissed off at your
wife will solve nothing other than
you not being married anymore
being pissed off and angry and raged out
will solve nothing other than your kids
will learn he's not safe to be around
and what i would say is look back on the
last 10 years and say has this has this
is this operating strategy worked in my
home the answer is no
so the true answer is okay i gotta do
something different
i'm taking a knee
i'm saying i'm sorry
hang on the line here i'm gonna send you
a copy of my new book i'm gonna send you
two things i'm gonna send you a copy of
my book and i'm sending the digital one
so you can listen to it in the car while
you're driving okay i'm gonna send you
an audio book and the new book on your
past change your future
my guess is brian if you and i talked
long enough we would go back to when
you're a kid because some of these
stories have been rattling around for a
long time
what i'll tell you is
you are too good of a man
and you work too hard
and you love too deeply
to have this little peace in your life
to be this lonely to be this all by
yourself trying to hold this thing
together
and i'll give you the tools to start
healing that okay
i'm grateful for you appreciate you and
i gave you hell to begin this call i'm
not gonna apologize for it but i
appreciate you being honest and
going back and forth with me
i love you and i want you to have peace
in your life peace in your home and
peace in your family you deserve that
your kids deserve that your wife
deserves that
and the grandkids you've never met they
deserve that too we'll be right back
it seems like everybody is talking about
how crazy the housing market is right
now and how powerless homebuyers feel
mix that with the stress of moving and
life change and job change and you've
got a tornado of anxiety fueling one of
the biggest purchases you'll ever make
this is not a good idea so if you're a
new home buyer right now my advice to
you is to focus on what you can control
like the people you choose to help you
in the home buying process
you need folks like my friends at
churchill mortgage churchill is a ramsey
trusted provider that's been helping
people with their home mortgages for
decades and their home buyer edge
program will help you skip a bunch of
the stress here's how it works apply to
become a churchill certified home buyer
and cap your interest rate for 90 days
then you'll get a 5 000 seller guarantee
to help your offer stand out so go ahead
take a deep breath because churchill has
your back
check them out at churchillmortgage.com
delony and get the homebuyer edge today
this is a paid advertisement mls id 1591
nmls consumeraccess.org equal housing
lender 1749 mallory lane sweet 100
brentwood tennessee 37027 programs are
for select loan types only and are not
available in all states or locations
all right we're back let's go to becca
in seattle home of pearl jam and allison
change what's up becca
hi how are you partying what about you
i'm good thanks for talking to me again
of course uh yes hey this is the second
time the last caller called about a year
ago or however many months ago and we
got another repeat call it's fantastic
so what's up
um
so the last time we talked we were i was
just before
deployment number one with my daughter
and now we are knee deep in deployment
number two oh no
it's okay we uh we learned a lot from
the first one and it's completely
different and nothing that happened in
the first one applies to the second one
it's like having kids man it's like i
got this figured out like nope
right um
so she my daughter is three um and she
is a nut
and she's absolutely great she
holds on so tight
to everything and everyone um especially
me
and so i feel like i'm kind of
sorry i'll get to my question um so how
do i no no no no no no no no that was
important what were you gonna say you
feel like what
i feel like um
i'm kind of at the end of my rope yep
sort of
i'm
so tired um
i'm so tired and this actually has to do
with that um and so i uh
so how do i create boundaries with my
three-year-old without weaponizing our
relationship or making my presence a
punishment for her specifically at
bedtime oh that's so good you are using
my words against me and i love it
i love it
yeah in the car you know i listen to
your stuff and i love it and so i heard
that and that like it keeps rattling
around in my brain because i'm trying to
transition her into doing
bigger girls others have big girl things
but like bigger kid things and being a
little bit more independent and our days
are great like i work full time and so
she goes to a daycare where she loves it
she's so happy her teachers are amazing
they they know every transition we have
great communication with them we come
home we go to the park we have dinner we
read books we do bath time and then
bedtime comes
and she just looked at me with those big
brown eyes that i gave her and she's
like don't leave me yes and i'm like
dude
and i i don't know if i lost whatever
mom jean i was supposed to have because
i can't
do like co-sleeping i will be awake all
night it scares me her room is her safe
place and so for her to be in my room
i'm like she's gonna fall off the bed
and she's gonna crawl off the bed and
climb on a dresser like i i don't sleep
when she's in my room
and so we've been doing this since she's
three and i've been the only person
getting up to get her and so i can't
remember the last time i slept through
the night which is not a big i feel like
this is a very common parent thing but i
because i've been doing that now i feel
like i
i'm not a super emotional person and i
just break down crying because i'm so
tired yes and then i
my default reaction is kind of anger and
i've worked really hard in my life to
not do that and to go towards other
things and to like take a second and and
not do that and now i feel like i'm i
don't even realize how angry i am until
my brain comes around to realizing how
mad i am and i'm like i'm not
i'm i feel like i'm behind yeah
oh man i would
if your husband wouldn't kill me i would
hug you if you were sitting right here
um
i haven't he wouldn't he wishes he could
hug his chair i know he does i know he
does um
i have a couple of let me write these
down cause i'm afraid we're gonna um
okay
man
number one
let's let's pretend there was no
deployment
three o'clock i mean three-year-old and
bedtimes
is the worst okay
so you've got 20 things happening all
the same time hear me say this i have a
smile on my face you're doing a great
job
okay and you didn't just hear the last
call where we were yelling at each other
you are doing a great job okay
and the chaos you feel and the this is
never gonna end
all that is i mean i couldn't tell you
how normal it is okay yeah
um it doesn't help but it doesn't make
it like oh cool we're all struggling
with expensive beef that doesn't make us
less hungry but it makes us feel less
crazy okay yeah
the two words i heard you say i mean i
heard you say one word a lot and then
another word just kept coming to me okay
um and that sounded all woo like i have
a word spoken to like not like that
um and and
feel free to push back on anything okay
okay you said i feel i feel i feel i
feel i feel a lot okay yeah here's a
crazy thing that happens when it comes
to feeling a lot
is your kid
can quickly become our emotional
regulation blanket
i feel better i'll just use me i feel
better when i'm hugging my six-year-old
daughter
when i'm watching some knuckleheaded
little movie whatever kid nonsense they
want to watch about dinosaurs and
dragons i don't know what the crap are
watching
i lit my heart rate will slow down and
i've tracked it on like a wrist strap
when she snuggles up next to me for
about 20 or 30 minutes
and
intuitively she feels that
yeah
and so the more
exhausted and spun out you get this is a
crazy thing
the more she can feel like i have to be
near her to help
i've noticed that she's last month she
started getting really angry
and i was like this is it's
and i know why like i and i've listened
i know she's a sponge and she picks up
everything and so and especially because
it's just her and i and so i'm the
person that she's getting all this from
and so that's why now i'm like
well she's she's slowly developing her
own too right it's it's this weird mix
here's the other word that keeps coming
to mind to me tell me i'm wrong
you sound really really tired you sound
really exhausted you sound really burned
out can i tell you what you really sound
i'm sure you sound completely and
totally alone
you sound really lonely
yeah
is that true
yeah
i imagine you're working all day and
she's a daycare and you want to make
sure that i've got to do both parent
roles
so i've got to spend extra time at the
park at dinner having fun reading books
singing songs doing bath and then right
i've got to make sure all that time is
accounted for otherwise my daughter will
fall off because husband's gone and this
is what moms do and we gotta do this we
gotta do this
your daughter would benefit tremendously
if one night a week you got a babysitter
that she loved
or sent her to a friend's house a parent
another parent and you went hung out
with some girlfriends and just hung out
she would benefit so much
but she's already gone all day it
doesn't matter i already i i know but
but you're coming you're coming home
with a hole in your heart
and part of that hole is your husband
fear but you're coming in with a hole in
your heart which is connected to
connectivity to a tribe
your body recognizes you are all alone
it's a very normal response
and yet
you feel this guilt and obligation to do
every minute of every day with her that
she's not a daycare because i'm such a
terrible mom that i send her to daycare
right so all this
guilt factory
i'll push up i will push against on that
because
like i love having she has a place to go
she has friends she is she's not upset
when she goes so i'll push against that
i don't feel guilt for sending her to
daycare okay like in that specific
scenario good but i do feel guilt if she
comes home and she sees me and she's so
excited to be with me and then i like
push her off on someone else i don't
want her to feel like i don't want her
around gosh because she's i like her
she's great she's right three she's
little like she's i'm not gonna i'm not
that person that says my three-year-old
my best friend
but she's not my best friend good um she
knows she needs to see you have a best
friend
oh yeah
and we need a model that we need to we
here's what we need to do for her
we need to let her off the hook that
it's her job to hold center of this home
because she's just three
she's not strong enough to hold that
center so once a week we're going to let
her know no mom goes to
mom's going out with her friends you've
been playing with your friends all day
now mommy's going to go play with her
friends
and she may be like no mommy no
for the first few times and then it's
gonna become the way it is
mommy goes and plays with her friends
and then what we're gonna teach that
three-year-old is man having a community
was so important
that once a week mom left her kid to go
to be with community because the only
way she could fully parent
was to be fully tailored to subs to a
gang
that's the only way it works
is that fair yeah and that's really
really hard
yeah
because that means mom's gonna have to
go be awkward and be weird and show up
and be the new girl and the news
i know it's the worst
and so we let our kids be our excuse and
we let netflix be our excuse and we let
our workout program be our excuse we
have dude i'm the king of excuses the
king the king read
too many books i like to read yep
for real did you know i made a rule for
myself here's how the rule i made
um i go to all these great cities all
over the country doing events and things
and you know what i do i sit in the
hotel and read books like a loser like a
complete nerd and so this summer i made
a rule
when i go to a new city i gotta go walk
around
and so the rule i made is i have to get
a new tattoo in every city that makes me
go to a place that i'm gonna be
uncomfortable with people i don't know
and i have to spend a lot of time just
talking to people in awkward situations
and the last town i was in we were in
san jose i got a tattoo i was with kelly
and joanna and uh we were doing some
media there and i had the way i was all
splayed out i looked like i was getting
a proctology it was not comfortable and
i was just getting a tattoo on my arm
but it was not anyway you know i hung
out with a bunch of dudes there's this
red
awesome gangster dude getting a tattoo
on his neck and we were talking it was
all i got to meet all these people
i had to just put myself in that
situation then when i did it was fun
right it was fun and then i had to
explain to my daughter like dad why are
you keep drawing on yourself right all
that all that's part but i have to go
out and do those things i know the
science i know the reality of it i got
to make myself do it and that's where
you are okay now when it comes to the
sleeping thing
this is world war ii no this is world
war seven eight nine and ten the
co-sleeping not co-sleeping should we
should we not you even said i guess i
lost my mom gene no you're not failing
as a mom if you want a full night's
sleep okay you're not
you don't hate your kids because you
need sleep that's like saying i can't
take a full breath because i want my kid
to have more oxygen in the room it's not
at work
okay so how it works
um and some parents
they're they're some kids
are
just do better when they are co-sleeping
um there was some seasons we did that
there were some seasons that we forced
our kids into their room they couldn't
like you will be in your room
then there were some seasons we set up a
pallet on the floor
because i'm like you if somebody's in my
bed it's a weird thing but i just set up
some like made a blanket bed on the
floor and in the middle of the night you
can come in
if you wake me up you are choosing to
never come into my room again i'm going
to lock my door
but if you come in here and you get into
your special bed you can do that
but don't don't wake me up if you choose
to wake me up then you're choosing to
not come in here anymore
yeah you see what i'm saying or
um tonight is sleep night for mommy and
so you're gonna have to stay in here
tonight you're sleeping in here
the more your child doesn't feel like
they are keeping you together
the more they can begin to practice
sleeping
yeah that makes sense
yeah um
can i tell you this go ahead no go ahead
go ahead go ahead
um i
we've i've
we've had to do a lot of transitions
with her and so even just like finally
we're at the place where i can hang out
in her room for a couple minutes we have
a set amount of time she's got this
little thing that plays audiobooks and
so i stay for one chapter and then mommy
goes and has stuff to do and so she's
okay she doesn't cry she's like okay
like once those chapters over she's like
bye mom go do your stuff and i'm like
all right cool and so i get out and do
my stuff and then at like midnight one
o'clock she's awake and her eyes are
open and she's like mommy why did you
leave me and i'm like all right
um
okay hold on we got to that okay i'm
gonna tell you something i just told the
caller before
we don't let three-year-olds buy beer we
don't let three-year-old smoke
so three-year-olds are gonna wake up and
say stupid three-year-old things
you didn't abandon your daughter you
didn't leave her
she just asked you a dumb question that
just bangs right on that mommy chord
right
i know and then i'm like well is it dumb
because no her dad is in here
like it's not and then
and then like she john you don't
understand like she
when when people visit like my sister
came to visit this summer and she was
here for a couple days and then for a
week my daughter was asking why auntie
left her
and so it's not it's like it's not just
me and it's not my husband's everyone
like anyone who comes into her life she
holds on so tight hey hold on she's
three
i know and i don't want her to feel that
here's what she's feeling she's just
learning how relationships work
and some relationships are here all the
time
and some people come and then they go
and then some jobs you have
there's extended periods of time where
we're gone
and there's gonna be extended periods of
time where they're home
and so when she asks hard questions you
have to remember she's three and the
only relationship picture she has is to
her teacher to a couple of knuckleheaded
three-year-old friends and to her mom
and to her dad
right
and so she has a picture of a
relationship with mom where mom always
stays
aunt susan looks just like mom cool aunt
susan's gonna stay forever whoa and
susan left after a week
yeah why did she leave why did she leave
why did she leave it's not it's not it's
not her pointing out
it's not like i asked kelly every day
why are you drinking again why are you
drinking
she does it she discovered a face she
doesn't drink at all
but like it's not like i'm like hey why
didn't you do this why didn't you like
that's
that is like i'm i as an adult i'm
asking that question because there's
like a performance issue or like uh yeah
a three-year-old's just trying to figure
out the boundaries of the world
yeah it's up to it's up to you as an
adult to choose to not internalize that
as some sort of performance metric that
says you're failing because you're not
you're doing so good
so good
and when she says the more matter of
fact you can answer those questions the
better
because she will be like a sponge for
your responses
okay so when she says mommy why did you
leave say because mommy needs to sleep
and then i'm on to my next thing and if
you need to go in your room and shut the
door and then cry and be like i'm the
worst one go do that but do it
take that from her
so that when she asked these questions
she's just trying to figure out the
boundaries why didn't kim leave why did
aunt susan leave why didn't whoever
leave because she's got her own home and
she has to go home and sleep in her bed
and but she slept in our bed yeah this
is our guest room and she slept in our
guest room but her home is there and
that's where her friends are and her
family is and that's where her food is
in her fridge and so she had to go home
that's where her puppy is and that's
where she's got to go home
and you can say you know be a gift i
really miss her when she goes
just like i miss daddy
it's sad when people we love leave huh
yeah it is
and now we're on to the next thing you
want to go watch a show you want to go
play you can go to the park right so now
we're into the next thing and i know
she's i know it's it feels so nuclear
and she's three and let me say it again
becky you are doing such a good job
such a good job
such a good job such a good job
don't equate every one of her questions
and every one of her concerns and every
one of her behavioral issues with
i have to make up because dad's gone
they're not all related some may be
amplified some may be exacerbated but
they're not all related all
three-year-olds ask we used to have to
tell my son
um
he used to say
everyone gets someone to sleep with but
me
he was actually right and it kind of
broke my heart because he's like oh i
sleep all by myself there's nobody in
here and i was like ah it's the worst
he's three and both of us stayed there
okay
you are doing a great great great great
job
great job and
dude
thank you for listening to the show i'm
so glad that you're with us call back
soon and hey i want to talk to this
husband of yours when he gets back i'd
love you all to both call and i'd love
to hear how y'all are gonna redo
re-entry after a second deployment thank
you for your service thank you for that
and thank that little three-year-old
girl for her service too ah i love her
we'll be right back
all right hey what's up we're back hey i
took too long on that first call today
so um we had a third caller and we're
gonna roll that call to the next show um
but real quick somebody sent me this
note um so i want to make sure i get to
it's just an important question um
the question's from ashley and she
writes on
june 27th dr john said rest can be can
feel stressful
if busyness is how you medicate
and i think i may have posted that on
social media or reposted that from
somebody else maybe from my buddy ian
simkins but
she writes how do we do that nothing
i've tried helps me feel relaxed not a
beach trip not a massage exercise helps
my anxiety but it doesn't help me feel
relaxed
please elaborate
here's what i found and i've talked
about this recently on the show
if your identity
is in how busy you are
or if busyness doing doing doing doing
doing i've got another thing i got to
look at my list i got to make sure this
gets done if this doesn't get done i got
it all done i've done my things and i
got to go to these things once i get my
list done then i can go work on the
garden once i get the garden finish then
if that's your life
then rest then getting a massage going
to a beach and doing nothing will feel
like utter hell
your body it'd be like i drink
in the eve that's gonna look great when
somebody clips that if you're somebody
who drinks after work to feel better
like or just to take the edge off if you
like eat a drink after a hard day
and you do that every day for a week and
then for a month and then you have a
hard day and you don't drink your body
will feel terrible
it will feel terrible and so we often
think i'm just gonna go get a massage
i'm just gonna go to the beach and lay
on the beach for a week
if busyness is how you deal with the
the pain in your life if busyness is an
identity if being busy and running and
gunning it go go go go i'm a ceo or i'm
a small business owner and then i run a
marathon on the weekend and then i've
got my kids and six different things if
that's you
then simply doing nothing will feel like
torture
so
um i think i mentioned this um i tried
that and by the way
this is me
this is me
busyness is my medication i don't do
drugs i don't i don't hardly drink at
all um
i
i'm busy and busy is my heroine it's my
numbing device
i just take on too many things i say yes
to everything and all right so that's my
that's my problem that i gotta work
through
um
so what i used to do is i would be so
busy until i was about to collapse and
then we'd go my wife and i would go away
for two or three days because i was such
a cheapskate and um i couldn't roi a
vacation and so let's just go
and then i think i mentioned on the show
i would have a big crazy dinner because
we're finally on vacation and i'll have
a couple of drinks because we're finally
on vacation and then let's do something
in the morning and i'd be like no i'm
finally sleeping in
and then suddenly it's 11 30 or 12 the
next morning just watching episodes of
the office reruns on some hotel tv
and then i go eat again because the only
thing to pick up my blood sugar is
another meal and then
just within a couple of days i'm
exhausted i'm more exhausted i'm kind of
grumpy to be around and my body starts
itching
i'll start checking my work email i'll
start like trying like trying to do a
project that's down the road i just
started itching i got to do it got to do
this last time
um
my wife and i took a long vacation
and on that vacation i think i mentioned
this on the show
we were highly intentional about a
couple of things we exercised like crazy
um i took full advantage i saved my
money for weeks for months and
i visited the spa several times like i
got several massages and i put the money
in to make sure i don't just we just got
money phone from this guy we're gonna
make sure that i've got time for this
because touch is important working it
all out is important
and we got out in nature a lot and then
we booked some we're gonna go do these
things together
and being with other people number one
she's my best friend on the planet she's
awesome
doing things together with hers is
enjoyable for me so that was number one
i had somebody else with me we had some
very clear things that we were not going
to cancel
and i was moving my body
i after day three entered a state of
rest that i have not experienced ever in
my that i have any sort of recollection
the the last couple of days of this week
getaway
um i had more important thinking
i had more peaceful thoughts i had more
hey i really need to work on this just
more clarity
and so those three things
if busyness is how you medicate
then when you get away
make sure you do it with somebody else
or other people that you have community
with
make sure you are exercising
do too much
so not don't overdo it and injure
yourself
but make sure you're going to go to the
gym in the morning and sign up for a
yoga class we paid 10 bucks and we went
to just some rando yoga class in the
evening i did not want to go i did not
want to do that it was worth going and
then we went on another long hike the
next day and then i went back to the gym
later that evening right i just kept i
kind of pushed it pushed it pretty hard
and
then we had some appointments that we
didn't miss
and then we had one crazy get off the
rails meal it was awesome it was
ridiculous
and
uh but we ended up eating a lot more
sensibly throughout the week and it just
made us all feel better and we felt
better we were in better moods and we
were better moods we were able to rest
right
so that's what i'll tell you if you
struggle with busyness as a drug
you got to deal with the core issues
what are you running from what are you
running from what are you running from
so it's a great great question ashley
and i hope my answer helps um i love
these questions and you write them in
and i'll start doing a better job of
answering these email questions we get
some great ones in
um but
hopefully i answer your question there
we'll be right back
hey what's up now that my new book own
your past change your future is out in
the wild we've been hearing reviews and
feedback from readers and wow i'm so
grateful and one of the things i've been
most excited about hearing is that this
book is not just for people who are
healing from terrible traumatic
experience or other big scary things
from their past
this book is for everyone in every walk
of life the single 30 year old looking
to sharpen their mind the 25 year old
hoping to make new friends the parent
who's tired of seeing their kids eyes
glued to a screen but who doesn't know
how to re-enter their life people coming
out of abusive relationships
everyone and this book isn't me talking
at you this book is me walking with you
because i've been there too
to better understand and improve your
mental relational and emotional health
please check out own your past change
your future at johndaloni.com today
that's
johndaloney.com today
right as we are back the uh song of the
day is a song i've never heard by a band
i've never heard of
are you a fan of this band
it is a she it's not a band okay um
it's called night bird it's not like
it's like birdie
night birdie that's what she goes by she
was on america's got talent um and she
recently passed away from cancer okay so
i'm i wasn't familiar but sarah is and
she's got a great there's a great story
that goes with it it's a beautiful song
night birdie
excellent
song is by night birdie i'm gonna make
sure i listen to this is gonna be the
next song i listen to it's great song
sarah
excellent song's called it's okay
and it goes like this i moved to
california in the summertime i changed
my name thinking that it would change my
mind
i thought that all my problems would
stay behind i was a stick of dynamite it
was just a matter of time
oh dang oh my now i can't hide said i
knew myself but i guess i lied i have
heard this song this is tremendous
it's okay if you're a little lost we're
all a little lost and it's all right
and if you're lost we're all a little
lost and it's all right it's okay it's
all right and i wrote a hundred pages
but i burned them all i drove through
yellow lights and i didn't look back at
all i don't look back at all i don't
look back at all and you can call me
reckless i'm a cannonball i don't know
why i take the tight rope and cry when i
fall
ah dang oh my now i can't hide said i
knew what i wanted but i guess i lied
it's okay
if you're lost we're all a little lost
and it's all right and this is what we
do on the show man we sit with folks who
are lost and we'll see you soon